now there's been a surge in violence
across West Africa Sahel region the
number of people killed in attacks in
Burkina Faso Mali any share jumps from
717 2016 to more than four thousand last
year it's largely because of a
combination of attacks by armed groups
and inter-communal violence remote areas
where the state's presence is weak are
especially vulnerable the humanitarian
cost is also growing the UN estimates
half a million people have been
displaced a tenfold increase in three
years let's me to our regional
correspondent amédée Therese was in
Nigeria's capital for his night
Nigeria's capital Abuja amid the death
toll from this latest attack jumping
significantly what more are you learning
about the circumstances of the attack
itself
well basically like you said these are
areas that are less protected if you
look at the countries of this hell they
have vast and largely and manned the
country is able to police their borders
the answer is no do they because simply
simply because they don't have the
manpower and resources to do that
so these groups these fighter groups
actually are getting bolder and with the
conflict in Libya and other parts of
North Africa and West Africa these
groups are having a field day especially
targeting military military convoys and
military installations in that region so
the attack in Senegal was actually
carried out according to some sources by
rebels or other fighters who came in
from Mali just like the incident in
December 2019 when we saw 71 nature
soldiers killed in that attack now the
government is talking about killing 63
fighters in the attack on the military
base but a lot of people believe that
these attacks will continue simply
because the governments in the region do
not have the manpower and resources to
deal with these fighters who seem to be
trade and code well coordinated and also
have connections with foreign hardline
groups like al-qaeda like I saw like
groups like Boko Haram and if you look
at the dynamics of the region as well
it's not only the countries of Nazaire
Mali Burkina Faso Chad and the rest that
have these problems come to the other
side of the conflict in Nigeria
what you have is Boko Haram growing
balled up by the day attacking military
formations setting up roadblocks and
made highways in Nigeria abducting
people especially security forces and
their families so Oh a lot of people
think that before this situation gets
any better it will probably get worse so
yeah I did and the leaders of the region
the Sahel in particular have called for
international support there is already
foreign presence there the French troops
are on the ground as well as a regional
African force these leaders are meeting
the French president in Manion Macomb on
Monday in a few days what can we expect
from that what basically France will
probably promise more aid but it wants
to define the boundaries what what kind
of help it can give these countries and
how far it can go
already France has more than 4500 troops
in the region in this era in particular
and people in the region are actually
wondering why are these attacks
continuing for example in Mali there are
more than 15,000 international forces in
that country and we continue to see
violence not only in Mali but spilling
from Mali into neighboring countries
poor Tina Faisal Nazir all these
countries are not safe yet we have
thousands and thousands of international
troops in the region and people in the
region don't find it amusing at all and
a lot of people are angry calling for
withdrawal of these forces unless they
are willing to take action to stop these
fighters many people I spoke to one
person in particular in Bamako when Al
Jazeera was there just a few weeks ago
and he said look if the international
community wants this madness as he said
as he called it to end it will probably
end in one or two weeks simply because
there are enough resources on the part
of international forces the United
Nations if they want to end this they
can support the regional language to
deal with the problem however a lot of
people are not happy that with the
presence of many international troops on
their soil these
conflict continued to claim his life and
display thousands of people
Thank You Ahmed for that I made it his
life force in Abuja Nigeria